one of the things you may not have noticed,
or maybe you
noticed not noticing is that none of these
supposed fiscal conservatives are asking,
how would we pay for the war in Iran?
And we've been talking for a decade on this,
uh, issue about the political football that
is the deficit and our national debt.
And as we often say, we never have money for
healthcare.
We never have money for education, but we
always seem to have money for war and for
missiles and for contracts, for, uh, defense
contractors and all of that stuff.
And it's happening now.
It's happening front and center right now.
And as horrible as as the Iran situation is,
I do believe that it can be instructive on
a few levels.
We already talked about how the propagandizing
around Iran is very reminiscent of 2002 2003
Iraq.
The linking Soleimani to nine 11 much like
Saddam wasn't linked to nine 11 is another
example of that.
And so there's really a lot to learn from
this as we panic and try to prevent Donald
Trump from starting another war.
Over the last year we've seen the debate about
healthcare explode, single payer healthcare
proposals of different kinds have been put
forward.
Medicare for all a very prominent example
of a single payer healthcare program and you
have a lot of people on the right and left
because the left always cares about how much
things cost.
We just have answers for those questions.
There has been a question of how much will
Medicare for all costs?
Well, what where will we save and where will
we need new money and how much do we spend
per person now what would we spend under Medicare
for all?
What's the additional cost versus what we're
already spending?
What kind of a payroll tax would we need on
employees and employers to get it all to balance
out?
So on and so forth.
These are all very good questions which the
left and me personally, we like to think about
this with anything that government does on
the right you see a lot of concern trolling
around, uh, the costs, um, because they only
care about the cost when it's something that
they don't want to pay for.
And then you see Donald Trump for political
reasons to take attention away from his impeachment
to try to get himself reelected because he
believes it will help is starting to try to
escalate with Iran with a political assassination
and no Republicans other than the lone libertarian
here or they're saying, wait a second guys,
can we afford this?
Can we spend all this money on a war with
Iran?
Which would would likely cost trillions of
dollars.
How much will this cost?
Where are we going to get the money?
How many lives will be lost?
Where are we going to pull money from?
And it can be very easy to forget when there
is not a drive to war that the entire right
wing fiscal concern trolling is merely that
it's concern trolling.
They do not really care about the spending
as long as it's spending on things they like.
Period.
I tweeted yesterday quote, but how would pay
for the war in Iran?
What about the deficit?
Do the numbers balance and there were some
very interesting replies including doesn't
matter.
It fits the neo-conservative world view to
conquer.
Absolutely correct.
This is never actually about money.
It's about they don't like Medicare for all
and they like attacking countries.
Another tweet pointing out a similar idea
which said, cuts in social programs, education,
healthcare, increased military budget and
an even bigger deficit.
You can't put a price on freedom, meaning
election Wars cost a lot.
They cost lives and then I was also glad to
see one person actually use the term concern
trolling and their reply to me saying quote,
it's almost as if the hand wringing and Pearl
clutching over budgets and deficits when it
comes to anything beneficial to the general
population is just concerned trolling.
That is absolutely correct.
If you're wondering how do we pay for all
of the social programs that we want?
Look at Donald Trump's own tweet where he
said, quote, the United States just spent
$2 trillion on military equipment.
We are the biggest and by far the best in
the world.
There's the cash for your social programs.
It's a sick reality that we are leaving living
in.
But I hope you know any, any of the future,
uh, calls that I'm going to get about.
But, but David, how much, how much is this
going to, how much will it cost to make sure
nobody goes hungry?
How much will it cost to make sure no one
has a medical bankruptcy?
Where are you right now and why aren't you
asking that question about what's
going on
in Iran?